[Music]
from calorie count to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between coca-cola in the uk and the us
this is food wars
[Music]
in the uk regular coat comes in eight
portion sizes starting with this mini
can which is 150 milliliters then we
have three options which all include 250
milliliters of coke then we have our
standard cam which is 330 milliliters
our standard plastic bottle is 500
milliliters from there we move up to
this bottle which is one liter 1.25
liters
1.5 liters and 2.25 liters it's worth
noting that these ones are only stocked
by a limited number of shops including
iceland the supermarket chain not the
country and in the us our classic coke
comes in these sizes the mini can which
is 7.5 ounces then this mini bottle
which is eight ounces then we jump up to
the standard 12 ounce can that also
comes in a little 12 ounce bottle from
there we got this guy which is the 16.9
fluid ounces aka 500 milliliters then we
have a 20 ounce bottle and finally our
biggest the 2 liter
which is also
67.6 ounces now that means as far as
coca-cola classic is concerned the uk's
largest site is actually 12.5 percent
larger than that in the u.s there is a
reason why we're specifying regular coke
here the uk government brought in a
sugar tax which raised the price of
sugary drinks in an effort to reduce
people's sugar consumption instead of
raising the prices of some of their
drinks what coca-cola did was just to
make the sugary versions of their drinks
a little bit smaller for example how the
normal largest size of regular coke is
1.5 liters
whereas the largest size of coke zero
is two liters whereas here in the us we
don't have a specific sugar tax so we
can get our bottles of classic coke and
diet coke in the same size and for the
same price as a consequence of the uk
sugar rules it actually means that the
2.25 regular coke isn't our largest
bottle size that crown
goes to this
the 3 liter diet coke bottle now this
absolute unit is 50 larger than the
biggest bottle in america if you're
doing like a party maybe if you're
buying that for yourself like you've got
you've got a problem
i'm sorry that is ridiculously huge and
really hilarious now i want to point out
that on walmart.com
they have
this three liter bottle of diet coke on
it but it's not available anywhere so my
assumption is at one point in the united
states there was three liter bottles
available but if walmart doesn't have it
i'm assuming it isn't anywhere that
being said in terms of multi-pack
options the us still comes out on top
our single largest multi-pack is the 35
pack of 12-ounce cans let's get a
picture of that in the screen
i ordered it online and here's what they
sent me
24 pack
and nine loose cans now crackers are
wrong but what's 24 plus nine it ain't
35. when i emailed the place that i
bought it from they said oh sorry you're
missing two cancels refund you the two
cans and i'm like no i don't want the
two cans i want the 35 pack because
that's what i'm doing for this video and
they just sent me two dollars back so
thank you for that anyway so then i go
nuts to this i'm going to walmart.com
give me the 35 pack buy enter and then
they
sent me
three 12 packs which is more than 35
cans so i guess technically they're
being generous but once again it's not
that i need 35 cans of soda i need the
35 can pack for this video specifically
there's a 35 can pack somewhere in
america and everyone's just sending me
roughly 35 cans of soda thank you for
that our largest single item is this
this is a 24 pack of 330 milliliter cans
which comes to a total of seven point
nine two liters
[Music]
here is everything that's in regular
coke carbonated water sugar fructose
currency color caramel 150 degrees is
natural flavor natural flavorings
including caffeine now obviously we
don't get a full ingredients list
because the recipe of coca-cola is a
closely guarded secret at the world of
coca-cola in atlanta there's reportedly
a vault which contains the secret
formula written down on a piece of paper
who cares if the recipe gets loose
coca-cola
no one's gonna edge you up pepsi can't
beat you who cares i mean how do you
even make cola you probably just go to
the factory and eyeball it and figure it
out it's not super famous because you
don't know how to make it it's super
famous because they edged everybody out
you won do you i don't care do you want
the recipe i couldn't care less so what
do we know about the recipe well there
is one obvious difference and that's the
use of high fructose corn syrup in the
us
versus the use of sugar in the uk corn
syrup is everywhere in american food
it's cheaper for manufacturers to use
because the government gives subsidies
to corn farmers keeping the corn supply
high and the price is low should you be
worried about consuming high fructose
corn syrup the short answer is not
really some studies have suggested that
the negative effects of sugar tend to
come from fructose rather than from
glucose but the high fructose in high
fructose corn syrup only relates to its
fructose content in relation to other
corn syrups it actually still has less
fructose than table sugar or than honey
the main difference it causes might be
the taste you've heard americans talk
about mexican coke you can find in most
mexican restaurants and in some grocery
stores next to the regular coke in the
glass bile mexican coke is made with
cane sugar our regular coke is made with
high fructose corn syrup people tend to
like the mexican coke more because
there's a sweeter sugary taste so right
now to compare
and contrast i'm going to do a blind
taste test of both american coke
and max and coke hang on
and
harry was nice enough to send me
a united kingdom coke i've also got some
british coke some mexican coke and some
american coke i'm not going to blindfold
myself and let our camera operate to
sarah pour the cokes out for me
i'm blindfolded i don't know which one's
which i'm going to try them one after
the other and try and figure out which
one's which i'm going to start on the
right
see it could just be mind games but that
doesn't taste
like exactly what i'm used to number two
oh okay that one tastes pretty good
number three these two taste pretty
similar
this one tastes a bit weird for some
reason i'm gonna guess that this one is
american
on the right i was expecting more of a
difference i'll be honest i'll go with
british in the middle mexican on my left
put them in front of me and then i'll
unblindfold myself
wow okay that was mexican coke
i was right about british
i just got mexican and american coke
mixed up wow okay a lot of people have
really hyped up mexican coke to me and
i honestly like that was my least
favorite of the three
[Music]
it is exactly the same so i'm gonna go
uk mexico usa
wow really
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm so great at pointless things
any other ingredients to look out for
well one of them might be caramel color
as we know certain classes of caramel
color have a byproduct which has been
linked to causing cancer unfortunately
the caramel e150d that coke in the uk
uses is one of these classes we reached
out to coca-cola here in the us to see
if that was the case because the type is
not specified on the label they told us
that it is in fact the same
e150d caramel color in the states but
what about diet coke it still contains
caramel color but instead of using sugar
and corn syrup to sweeten it in the u.s
it's sweetened with aspartame and in the
uk it's sweetened with aspartame as well
as acid sulfam k the good news is that
both the eu and the fda say that acid
sulfa is safe for consumption in terms
of the difference with coke zero in the
u.s our coke zero uses ace k as well as
aspartame rumors have existed for years
claiming that aspartame causes cancer
but it turns out that that is likely to
be false the claims originated from some
italian researchers way back in 2005. i
feel like i heard about that in the 80s
but okay people were quick to call their
methods and results into question the
fda says the use of aspartame as a
general sweetener is safe while the
european food safety authority says
studies do not suggest an increased risk
associated with aspartame consumption
for leukemia brain tumors or a variety
of cancers
there's a cool side effect for coke
using these artificial sweeteners you
might not know them because they're so
much more sweet than sugar per pound
there's a tiny amount of them dissolved
in your diet coke compared to the amount
of sugar that's in a classic coke that
means a can of coke is denser than that
of a diet coke so when you put
said coke and water
to the bottom diet coke
close
one other room we felt compelled to
address was the role of cocaine in
coca-cola this dates right back to the
1800s when the drink was invented
coca-cola's official stance on this is
that there's never been cocaine in any
of its products what it does seem to
contain however is coca extract coca is
the plant from which cocaine is
extracted fluid extract of cocoa was one
of the ingredients in a list this
american life discovered which was
reportedly a recipe for an early version
of coca-cola and it seems like they're
still using it in 1988 a coca-cola
spokesperson said ingredients from the
coca leaf are used but there is no
cocaine in it and it all is being
tightly overseen by regulatory
authorities what's fun is that coca-cola
got a specific exemption from the united
nations in order to keep using coca
extract as an ingredient specifically
article 27 of the single convention on
narcotic drugs of 1961. it's only one
facility the u.s license to import and
process coca leafs through a special
deal with the dea it is owned by the
stepan company and it's in maywood new
jersey according to the peruvian
officials they buy around 100 metric
tons of dried peruvian cocoa leaves each
year they reportedly process them and
decoconize them taking all of the
cocaine out of them the cocaine is sold
to hospitals for use as an anesthetic
and the cocaine-free extract is then
sent to coca-cola for use in their
products coca-cola's official line on
the subject is quote coca-cola does not
contain cocaine or any other harmful
substances
and cocaine has never been an added
ingredient in coca-cola end quote but
it's fair to say that cocaine and coca
extract are not the same thing so the
latter might in fact be one of their not
so secret secret ingredients
[Music]
here are all the coca-cola products in
the uk that you won't find in the u.s
and here's all the coca-cola items
you'll find in the u.s that you cannot
find in the uk you want to start with
two exclusive flavors you can get in the
u.s you can't get in the uk and these
two right here cherry vanilla and orange
vanilla cherry vanilla seems pretty
standard i think i've had this a bunch
of times it's great it's refreshing i
enjoy it we can't get cherry vanilla in
the uk but we can get cherry and we can
get vanilla so i guess i can make my own
oh
oh god
panic over
the smart thing to do would be to mix
these in a glass but not a smart man
[Music]
pretty good
the only exclusive coke flavor we can
currently get
the only exclusive coke flavor we can
currently get in the uk is this one
which is diet coke sublime lime as the
name suggests it's just diet coke
flavoured with lime next up
caffeine-free coca-cola not to be
confused with caffeine-free diet coke
which is what you guys have over there
in the uk
that's your only caffeine-free option
for shame this one is delicious it
actually tastes just like coke uh it's
perfect for after 2 p.m we want to keep
drinking soda like me but if you like
caffeine and you want a little bit of a
boost
coke energy i believe is available in
both countries but one exclusive coke
energy flavor you can't get in the uk is
this the coke energy
zero sugar the coke energy drinks are
being phased out i can't imagine why i
think they're actually really good in
fact i went ahead and
got the other ones regular i only like
zero sugar but i do like
just regular
oh yeah
i'm into that
yeah thank you
that's good i mean like
energy meters going up julie
going up
if you're like me and you love soda and
coffee coke in the u.s has you covered
with these we got caramel vanilla
vanilla no sugar
dark blend and dark blend zero sugar oh
my god i sincerely love these so much
zero sugar can go there
which one do i want
it's the spot the i want to jack my
caffeine level through the roof spot
dude coke and coffee is good together
has anyone had two of these at the same
time i don't think they have
they don't mix very well
but
individually they're great
oh
i might have overdone it we don't have
coke coffees in the uk however coca-cola
owns costa coffee which is a coffee
chain in the uk and they produce canned
coffees so i guess again i can try and
make my own
so the issue here is uh they do do
americanos
but i got latte instead um
so
see how well milk combines with coke i
guess
yeah um
regretting quite a lot of things right
now
namely all the life choices that led me
to this point
cheers
[Music]
nope
not even a little bit no no no don't do
that no one else do that please god oh
just like really watery fizzy coffee
that is kind of sweet and stuff
no bad
the final exclusive range in the uk is
this coca-cola signature mixers
coca-cola work with bartenders to design
special cokes with different flavors
which are designed to be used in
cocktails these come with smoky notes
spicy notes herbal notes and woody
nights tag yourself i am spicy notes
cute
my stomach is making some weird noises
after drinking that no one else do that
please god ah
apparently these are designed to be
enjoyed with premium dark spirits now i
know nothing about mixology but
thankfully a bartender friend from
australia came through with a recipe so
now i'm going to use the smoky notes
coca-cola to put a food wars twist on a
jack's godfather highball comfortable
time
slight hiccup don't have a bottle opener
god this is either gonna work or i'm
gonna break my keys and be locked out of
my house
[Music]
improvisation
slash alcohol
it does smell quite smoky harry was kind
enough to send me this so now i have one
as well it just says pour ingredients
into an ice-filled glass formally
apologize to
any actual bartenders who are watching
this
while i'd butcher your profession 30
milliliters of tennessee whiskey we have
and then 20 milliliters of discerning
a delightful smoky coke
nicely mixed together
and there you have it thanks to coke
we've got our own spin on a jax
godfather high ball cheers
that's delicious um
yeah i'm not gonna make that drink
because i don't have all that stuff so
i'm gonna go ahead and make a joe high
ball first get yourself the biggest
glass available step two no ice find
yourself some whiskey
[Music]
okay
cheers my man
oh man
what is in this if i was to do it again
i'd use less of this
[Music]
it's iced tea guys
i'm like a drink whiskey that's really
gonna work
you know what tastes like
flat coke oh man i'm getting a headache
though last but not least in the u.s you
have the option to order customized coke
bottles check out the one i made joe
and harry
[Music]
here's everything that's in a 500
milliliter bottle of coca-cola in the uk
and here's everything in that same
bottle of classic coke in the us
that means that the uk's version
actually has slightly more calories in
it than the us we have more sugar and
for some reason our coke has a little
bit of sodium while the uk seems to have
none obviously the main thing to look
out for here is the sugar 500
milliliters in both the us and the uk
contains over 100 of your daily
allowance 53 grams of sugar
it does put in perspective doesn't it
you never see it laid out like that but
that is how much sugar is in coke and i
drink a lot of coke that's concerning
also worth noting that both countries
put the same amount of caffeine in their
coke for reference the average cup of
filter coffee contains about 96
milligrams of caffeine so that's exactly
double the amount in this bottle of coke
interestingly diet coke is actually more
caffeinated than regular coke it's 63
milligrams in this bottle which is a 30
increase and it makes sense because our
cocoa coffee contains 69 milligrams of
caffeine per 12 fluid ounces if you do
the math to find out the figure per
ounce it's double the caffeine of a
regular coke but the real caffeine king
is my boy coke energy
whether you get the classic or the
cherry a 12 ounce can contains 114
milligrams of caffeine
which is triple the caffeine content of
a regular coke per ounce
yo
don't i know it i'm gonna chug as much
of this as i can without throwing up and
then see what we can do
god that's so gross the max i got to
there was 90 decibels which according to
this thing i found is about as loud as a
leaf blower which is pretty good